you know I've never done a character
seven years cuz they they killed me in
in U I killed you D yeah I know and that
was I killed you and I and I talked to
the writers I said listen when you do
write me off let licks kill me cuz I
figured that that would really be who
you became that was the thing that
pushed me over the no pun intended push
you out of window yeah yeah you told
them that I asked them I said listen
when you kill me let Lex do it and that
that and they it that was one one of the
most Pinnacle moments of the show to me
for my character anyways for us yeah and
the look you gave me it was almost like
I remember doing the scene with you I
remember and I don't remember a lot but
we're standing there about to push you
and you just looked at me
like letting go